what I want to do in this video is get a
better understanding of oligopolies and
we'll be talking about it
I'll they got pulleys we'll be talking
about it more in future videos and as
we've already talked about this part of
oligopoly is the oligo and I know I'm
completely mispronouncing it comes from
the Greek word for few and the Pali part
comes from the Greek word for sellers
and I don't want to confuse anyone
because the prefix poly the prefix poly
like in terms of polynomial or polymath
when it's a prefix poly often means poly
doesn't mean many but in this context
this comes from the Greek and once again
I know I'm mispronouncing it poly in I
think or Pauline which actually comes
from seller so this means few sellers
and what's interesting about oligopolies
are that they can sometimes act much
more like monopolies if they coordinate
or if they can still even if there are
few sellers even two sellers they can
compete fiercely and look much closer to
perfect competition so an example is if
they so let's say there are these few
competitors and let's say they
coordinate with each other they say hey
look we're going to be because there's a
few of enough of them that they can
coordinate they say hey look why don't
we restrict quantity so that we can
raise price and then we're essentially
maximizing our collective economic
profit so they are they are getting into
they are agreeing to coordinate and when
and this is illegal within the context
of most countries most most companies
are not allowed to do this in most
countries but when when this is going on
this kind of coordination between the
players and an oligopoly this is called
collusion this is called collusion or
we're saying that they are colluding and
if they have a formal agreement to
collude we call these players right over
here we call them we call them a cartel
we call them a cartel and they're
approaching their behavior is much more
is much closer to a monopoly than
they're essentially trying at least to
act together like a monopoly and the
most famous of all of the cartels is
OPEC you sometimes hear about the drug
cartel I'm not an expert
there I guess that's implying that
there's some form of coordination
there's some form of price-setting some
form of quantity restriction but the
most famous and maybe the one with the
largest impact is OPEC is OPEC and OPEC
stands for Organization of Petroleum
Exporting Countries and it's a group of
12 countries it's a group of 12
countries that collectively control 79
percent this is as of 2012 that
collectively controls 79 percent of the
world's oil reserves oil reserves so oil
reserves are the actual oil that's in
the ground or that the oil that we know
is in the ground obviously there's other
oil that we don't know where it is but
it's in the ground but this is 79
percent of the oil that we're aware of
that is in the ground and they control
about 44 percent of the production of
oil production of current oil production
so in a given month 44 percent of all
the oil in the world is coming from
these OPEC countries and there are
predominantly countries in the Middle
East but they now include countries that
are outside of the Middle East and they
have a formal agreement where they try
to restrict output so that they can get
the price to whatever price they want it
to be so they are at least they are at
least attempting attempting to act
somewhat like a monopoly they don't
control all the oil reserves they don't
control all of the oil production but by
coordinating it they can act like a
bigger player than they are individually
but what we'll see in future videos is
that even though it is good collectively
for them to do this for them to
coordinate in this way and it can't be
illegal because they're all countries
coordinating with each other so no one
can say hey what you're doing is illegal
because they're they're essentially
acting outside of any one country's laws
but what we'll see in the future is that
there's a huge incentive for any one of
these 12 countries to break to break the
agreement secretly to say okay I'm going
to restrict quantity just like all the
rest of you guys but then secretly keep
producing more on getting that higher
price that is that is being achieved
because everyone else is being is
restricted so it's actually very hard
even if you have a formal agreement to
maintain to maintain discipline within a
cartel now these that was an exam
Belov kind of trying to coordinate
trying to be collude trying to become
more like a monopoly there are many many
cases of oligopolies that at least as
far as I know are fiercely fiercely
competitive probably the most famous of
them are Coke and Pepsi coke Coke and
Pepsi so this would I guess fall under
the the sugar water market they both
take water and they place a lot of sugar
in that water and then they spend
millions or maybe even billions in some
circumstances on marketing to make you
convinced that somehow that what that
sugar in that water will will make you
cool or trendy or or you'll have more
friends or you'll be better-looking or
whatever else but they are fiercely
competitive these you know they could
coordinate and say hey let's raise the
price of it you know twelve ounces of
sugar water to a dollar or five dollars
and if you do it I'll do it as well but
they don't they compete fiercely on
price they compete fiercely on marketing
and that's actually where they really
really really compete and this is
actually a special case of an oligopoly
where you only have two players two
major players and this you would call a
duopoly do ah Polly other examples of
duopoly you can imagine Boeing Boeing
and Airbus if you fly on a commercial
aircraft especially a new commercial
aircraft and especially a large
commercial aircraft it is going to be
either a Boeing aircraft or an Airbus
aircraft Boeing is the u.s. manufacturer
Airbus is the European manufacturer and
although Boeing is always complaining
that Airbus is having is getting support
from the European Union and Airbus is
always complaining that Boeing is
getting support from the US they do
compete quite fiercely on price they're
both wining and dining countries and
airlines that are looking to buy new
planes or whatever other examples of
oligopolies that are more competitive
especially more competitive than
something like OPEC you have something
like the Airlines is going with that
airplane theme you have the airlines in
fact I gave I gave Airlines as an
example of an industry that it seems to
behave in a kind of a perfectly
competitive way the a seat on an economy
class seat on most airlines is fairly
undifferentiated
there's a lot of very good price
information in the airline industry
better than in almost every industry and
but you do have not too many competitors
they're all aware of each other they all
know each other's prices to some degree
they're looking at each other's prices
to figure out what their own prices
should be that's not like they have a
million competitors out there and they
can't keep track of everyone so airlines
they're not a duopoly so let me make a
line here airlines are not a duopoly but
they are definitely an example of a
oligopoly that where the market is
approaching is approaching perfect
competition and there's others you could
you could have something like the credit
card networks you have Visa MasterCard
MasterCard and American Express and
really these these two these first two
are the dominant ones but once again
very few players and they are not
coordinating or at least as you know as
far we don't know that they're
coordinating and and so they are they
are competing but there have been cases
of companies especially in oligopolies
where all of a sudden someone does find
out that there's some type of a backroom
deal where they say hey why don't we
coordinate and not raise not not raise
our production or we keep our prices
high and both of us kind of hold that
discipline and that's whether we're
where the government's have to get
involved and regulate and make sure and
make sure that between parties there
really isn't that there really isn't
this type of thing because from most
government's point of view they want to
push they want to push the parties out
there as close to perfect competition as
possible and we've seen the closer you
get to perfect competition the further
away you get from being a monopoly the
more efficient production you have the
larger total surplus you have and the
more of that total surplus goes to the
consumers